this is a second thought video made
possible by Squarespace
make your next move with a beautiful
website from Squarespace so you're bored
with life on earth and want to live
somewhere new understandable but where
to go the moon nah too close to home
Mars yeah too obvious everyone wants to
go to Mars
what about Venus it's close enough to
get there in just a few months more
exotic than Mars and you never hear
about anyone trying to visit Venus it's
been over 30 years since the Soviet
Union landed their last unmanned craft
on its surface it's settled you'll move
to Venus you pack your favorite
belongings and take off in your rocket
about three and a half months later you
arrive at your new home it's not much to
look at from space as Venus is always
covered in thick clouds oh well you're
sure it's nice down below the cloud
cover as your landing craft descends
through the thick clouds your
instruments give you some not so good
news the clouds are made up of toxic
sulfur dioxide and it's a little windy
than you'd like with wind speeds
reaching over 350 km/h that's ok it'll
probably be calmer below the clouds
right as you move closer to the surface
the temperature begins to rise and you
enter a thick haze the sulfur dioxide
rains down from above but the
temperature here 30 miles below the
cloud tops is so high that the rain
instantly evaporates into a poisonous
haze of sulfuric acid over 10 miles
thick at this point you're probably
getting a little nervous and with good
reason
the temperature is 315 degrees Celsius
and climbing fast as your craft touches
down on Venusian soil the temperature
has reached 465 degrees Celsius hot
enough to melt lead and the pressure
clocks in at 92 times that of sea-level
on earth the same pressure you'd feel
over a mile under Earth's oceans to make
things worse it's very difficult to see
the atmosphere reflects over 90 percent
of the light that hits it keeping the
surface shrouded in permanent Twilight
if you think you just picked the wrong
spot to land think again the whole
planet stays this incredible temperature
and pressure year-round all over the
surface okay
let's ignore the fact that your craft
would likely be completely melted and
crushed within minutes of touching down
and you
let's say you establish a pleasant
little home on the surface of Venus what
kind of life would you live for starters
you'd have to get used to a day on Venus
being longer than a year since the
planet is so close to the Sun it only
takes 225 Earth days to complete an
orbit but Venus also rotates very slowly
and one full rotation takes 243 Earth
days that means you could celebrate your
birthday twice every Venusian day you'd
also feel a bit lighter than back on
earth that's because Venus only has
about 90 percent of Earth's gravity man
that's about it for the positives the
atmosphere of your new home is
incredibly toxic meaning you could never
take off your spacesuit outside your
habitat assuming it even produces oxygen
you really couldn't even leave your
habitat without simultaneously melting
and being crushed into oblivion but what
if you didn't live on the surface what
if you lived in a floating habitat above
the cloud layer as you travel back up
through the thick atmosphere the
temperature begins to drop reaching a
much more reasonable 75 degrees Celsius
that's still hot but well within the
human limit for survival with protective
equipment the pressure also stabilizes
around one earth atmosphere you'd still
need oxygen tanks or a habitat that
provides breathable air and protection
from the heat and occasional acidic rain
but other than that you'd have a fairly
safe lifestyle your habitat would be
blown around the planet at over 300
kilometres an hour but there's nothing
to bump into so you'd be completely safe
as long as your habitat is structurally
sound and can withstand the corrosive
effects of sulfuric acid the biggest
problems you would face in your new home
would be how to produce food and water
if you could get the water food would
then be easy since the atmosphere is
rich in co2 which could be used to grow
crops after filtering out the sulfuric
acid getting your hands on water could
be pretty tricky though since Venus is
almost entirely devoid of water in any
form the sulfuric acid and sulfur
dioxide vapor clouds do contain trace
amounts of water but it would have to be
heavily treated and filtered before it
would be safe for use alternative
sources include shipping water all the
way from Earth or collecting it from
nearby asteroids both of which would be
incredibly expensive and difficult but
if you can manage it you'd be all set in
your new home above the clouds
no obnoxious neighbors to deal with
peace and quiet and a whole planet to
call your own until everybody else
catches on and snack
is up that sweet flying real estate oh
well looks like you'll have to move
again while you search for the next
planet to call home you should keep
track of all your research with a
professional website from Squarespace so
your Lander doesn't end up melting on
arrival with Squarespace it's not rocket
science to create your own personal
website Squarespace has tons of easy to
edit templates created by world-class
designers to get your shiny new website
up and running in a matter of hours
these days it's so important to have a
web presence to show off your work sell
merchandise or just to be noticed and
thanks to Squarespace it's a whole lot
easier than you might expect so if you
want to start a blog sell a product or
make a cool website to sell real estate
on Pluto I can't recommend Squarespace
highly enough to check out Squarespace
and support second thought visit
Squarespace calm / second thought today
if you enjoyed this video consider
subscribing to support the channel and
keep up to date on the latest content
and click the little bell to be notified
every time I release a new video you can
watch the rest of my space related
content by clicking here or if you're
really bored you can binge watch all my
content by clicking here thanks for
watching and I'll see you next week